[Music]
monica e riposi il impressi rooms with
the same high broadband deco by stan
and this time
to mention decoder and chi no inside
d'action no deco this directive so nice
to be transposed to national everywhere and
in europe is to undergo the  iii the pride
task of every politicians underhill ikea
sabaudi sector shooter juve rickli ali
we are a scintu trasposte co del
national legislation so that will be
aware rewards i task a cantello we will
have and replies the to stay penguin
of age we meet in the tongue  even il
pid long in the meantime national
rigoletto ken apply moody's in the
causes not for be there for most of the
scenes qui c'è in the cut scenes candy
dan immediately so there are trionfo
titus armeni nice to this entry tool sui
cia fornì very  important for easy fiber
roll out the first one is the
possibility to call gest in childbirth of the
territory re or of the territory and country
and to tweet in sé flexible way with
flexible agreement and disease e
possibi  li di tekken b explode vero
quickly and again the mistress and we
will not object of national regulator
budak 7 co investment plan b a the one
introduced e new bike o operator witches
di consale wave operator di super edolo essa
selling quadro operators d'asti the
science  fiction off di hall se l'on.le
operator è né i cubi again and small
type of operation that covers
numbero factories thanks to the aria ora i could be
quite all'ars in about e country o
religion l'actrice the most important
thing  when you have suchan operator des
corses real clients judo need
well yes dire come show you need to be
sure that this operator e se le gamin
not to its own commercial division and the
knot canto but obligation at lower cost
of bills ora studi said on it  but
he sees the direction of travel and long
as this is made available
made available s commercial off the
rough there ok occorsi testo pirri sono
hubble and bla bla bla batam in is not the
traditional typo regulation that  you
have seen in telecom steps from in di
hall consideration about marche power
witches but also power of course and
have incontro de customers il dio per
eto'o da senti control de castro nel
fate reason to apply e vi regulation
and very important 9th another one  isfor
dolls operator switch a del campetto per
eto'o si strofe commitments for instance
when the flying fi brains erta neri as
so deesis e possibility del re places di
traditional regulation e ne gann dos
commitment exchanges and currencies
vai di regoledo sam ed obligatory if
they  are better than any other
regulators luca so there are many to
handle stuhr che esplode to make life
simplicio operators e for customers di
a2 points
we're very worried about that takes
around fiber di slogan we are looking
mormora di overall cost of delivering e
file  of the network e non force of the two
well-known statham in guarin comes to the
ground work really groundwork and rimini
tamin by katyn for mission a
local liquid author  of hit eni show and beat of
guerre in europe nord est da reptiles
cisco de coster ed action directive that
exactly made for this is it has been
implement the wee dap sandown nel derby
terry guerre in europe probabili not
enough his we want to discuss here of
ubuntu silhouette her with udu e bit
more amin
io mai 6 abatesi slogan europe che ha
sin qui che discuss whether the problem
se gondry si whether the solution and
slim e b di poor bout modernizing
distretti in the next legislative cycle
we had done santin similar to for
microsoft deludes itself cod
now es simplified authors session pass
for microsoft berlin authors session un
single installation meager se providers
else if you ever it was possible two
industries aspect and hours dimension
could make the difference my and back
of obligation for goldman sachs oli
license spectrum by  twenty five of
spectrum flying tuenti hennequin to be
serious about his and above serve an
other e megan spectrum data store e di
bindi cyb  er photocall of open inflicts
matt gross ttx for kant respect bit
amin sync in too much his spectrum
essentials or operators to the
fantasticks is like the row auto fi.gi
in combination fiber of which is very
much need to have in full on one
fascia by unite spectrum my team his
the a we will make sud can of mayor and
applicable we have also simplified many
password regulation we are created the
same rules for consumers concerns in
europe to avoid consumer sales protected
product of no goal plating or cruz will be
a  giro however consumer protection we have
brand new set of tools for regulators to
apply in sé flexible way di hexis thing
rus life roosters amine del single
european termination retro void
everytime fine saitech tv sex lies in
a fixing dos reis over all the
direction travel ace morrow  band
floorman moore high speed robyn moore
five morra file clr tapes del sud
what we are a nepi of ram in the text
politics compromise yukinobu andrè per
s  anta ap battaglini sparto you see it can
create its own tweak tools with respect to
sync wait for coordination parties
insufficient etwas not what was our
origin proposal
and if you see amin nord scare in
an industry bout
ma tu screen min sunmizer many
aboudi options fi.gi terp  roster maybe
the commission di star wars right to ask
for discipline mall coordination of air
force we will insiste viva last i
libri times witness wiispeak indies
complexity ama 6 di 6 dia of creating
board le single market is one of those e
di hardcoreauto  banner
present here thirty indieframe proposes
intense legislation
the tool enti and the top of the 9 pina prud which
cis for europe and near the record
gas norma will complain about armenia nuns medici
the failure and which ebit you have understood
tg from a minimum must rwe set puddu amin
colletti  the milk of course of
institutes a setup project with it now
i think we are in situation weekend
proudly say we have
marketing europe si colma anch  e guide
all digital borders the muba ground io
don dei rom in chips
io che workshop favorite movie horror
football match by snow geoblogging free
flow plot his and his characters ove
single marker witches rado unique in the
world basic liam in you don't fight
another  year e o five hundred million
cities testis characteristics of ad
positive achievement witches 3 with
ribbon l'over the world europe isti only
region of the world that can't stand
intense i weekend introduced regulation
about d'età e the way they dalle artriti
boiardi only  larger in wish we have and
general data protection regulation del
gdp a we have comparisons the world and in
particular european act of complex ixus
saces auto balance of the right of rights
holder and direct auto balance users who
use copyright su copyright cruz sono
data protection in ussr  copyright no
taxation frau di fico triste subject su
hicks gliali younicef norma is that europ
exhibite dictate rules of gold the words
with this  is something to be proud
or not it up to you to design ice in cui
di riso nabli plaut suo these are good
part of the story dell'esc parto the
story is that europe il tremendo
sull'independent when he comes to
technologies and disease and  problems
and tremendously legging behind when it
comes to investment in infrastruxure
test part one in we should be good
connects to the best
possible speed and quality last
weekend on it snow b of the guide
connections so that for people kind of
dei think there fondamenta right away di
testa che e sweeping qui a boves to
remember cost e low tomorrow
web
dying bayless anne hurd 6 time we have
in economics ai golden shares some
science slowdown nor capital intensive
industry
investment the launch lies but spies
priority in mind
in front of such and social from the id henin
last front there is some economic
challenge politics ass.to hard I will
win them the war crimes and much as
possible investment simple
ad hong sik from home bureaucracy wish
directive by huawei order b and
reflection do not look at industry and goes
che milling to di it e business model no
a sin dai nas in from pipes and carrier all
pipes aminatu lei da un fabric structure
and get this ain '  t outcome of this e
change e e 4 si fici horse table cas
close far off system of very
interesting amin the snow necessiti tutu
collapse the value chain il gol
ramin in other business his eyes inc the
business and providing the network it
very very interesting one of  course
cash flow provider arssu stenebo le
su stands are denis dadis continuous
often del prices will go down
bicos enia of the new browser
i test google dow amazed me somehow festa
n faced with e  fa del fabric quality es
in every other products
amen coli di ma spire world one home one
is able to establish morderle scip2
equality and price a sint business o
providing high speed infrastruxure o
nixon e severi vero tre stint business
to be the border deceives much more
complex ue boksic st going on amin di
enterprise or the feature will lead and
sword of integrated solution that would
mix high speed computing cloud security
the network and his deliver probabili s
package so this is e neri aware of
course and many of dell'arch cloud
provider life plus in the world al look
in more moore bat il ashes hauer
telecom tradition telecom provider
related solace
we were so this is clearly e nella
guerra alliance campo place where the
hell is important buy da add ons in
telecom industries car of
contrary waves e  santi to say what we will due
micro a me be les fauves giganti
production horrors already tournée lazio
icing last we will have to see less
gottlieb i  l political direction to enel
with bike non so a che non li give you
god is my very humble opinion al
settente in time for what it's worth e
6 set
we have three mega trend dei pini tutu
luperi carefully the first one is europe
nice to be  on the tecnological forefront
henin sanchi technologies artificial
intelligence super computing blog chen
cui arno kia dea we need to be make sure
that europe is hoening o di essential
element codes from the value chain which
means important investments in arendi
in consistent investment between europe
and the member states  e
nell'ing eri lieti work by artico europe kenobi
dependent amin this is to risks and
probabili not the rise in tuffo nella
van sex said the second element e il
link della p2 this is a bossi close
demorde world becomes digital de mohr
debord cyber security  becomes edition
costs si soft course the week side e 9
digital society sua the one that
politicians a no more war focusing on
the issues a bossi  clarified security of
everything objects connects debbs
security network
we have now foundation of di rousse
perhaps also follow in europe then in
ai asteriti del nord e cyber security
regulation cyber security act and pushes
st prude yesterday balle parlament
no we entering diluire a witches
certification standards working  with
industry making sure that the seas the
label of european security achieve the
third trend is about securing the right
environment conditions for investing
indices l'economy isis prodi all velici
formi del soft di tut to have and large
market and well ramin customers qui c '  it is
empowered and possible to action purchase
produced services of internal market da
mansion we remember important and we are
just the beginning of the days wia
bolis barriers fa in Paese lotto to end
six components sabbath investment using
di aldridge instrument on we have a giro
p a legal  and local level to go
interaction that is best man friendly e
barmen e tu said x  tend ai purposes shwe rai
started we will look very carefully
modiste total cost of the liver i foro
operator fuori sneijder roll out fiber
round round europe and try to understand
how much discosto delivery and related
to barriers retta e ips bureaucracy
station no b day
entrai tuel  minister appearance
[Applause]